when you write songs you hear music
first not the lyrics I hear the music
first the only time that change was on
one song uh We Didn't Start the Fire
that's right and you hate that song I
don't hate the song I think it's
probably the worst musical thing I've
ever written because
you didn't write the music first yeah
but also you listen I mean try to find
the melody
so so you broke your you broke your
winning way of I mean song was a huge
hit but if you broke your way of
Performing you hear the music first and
then you try to find the lyrics and this
time you did it the opposite yeah I hate
the song I wrote the words I hate the
song I just don't think it's very good
musically I don't think it's much of a
Melody you perform that in in concerts
though right yeah we do it live yeah is
it difficult to remember the words yes I
think it's tremendously difficult as
long as I can pick up the first word of
this of whatever verse is coming up
Harry Truman Daughter's Day return on
Johnny Ray South Pacific Walton wings
and Joe DiMaggio
Monroe and then
then what and I'm looking at the
audience hoping to see somebody mouthing
the words right Joseph Stalin and if
somebody's gotten the wrong words I'm
screwed